Transcription: Claire Ghyselen
Relecteur: eric vautier
Je suis un petit peu embêté
parce que je devais vous présenter un truc
et je n’ai rien préparé du tout.
Alors je sais, ça ne se fait pas.
Mais je me suis dit que
ce n’était pas très grave,
on va bien trouver un sujet de discussion.
Vous voulez parler de quoi ?
Je sais ce qu'on va faire.
Vous allez me donner deux mots
et on va se faire un petit TEDx inédit,
un truc juste pour nous, OK ?
Quelqu’un a mot ?
Public : Anesthésie.
J-B Chauvin : Anesthésie ?
Public : Retraite.
JBC : Anesthésie, retraite : non,
ça va ensemble.
Anesthésie,
(Rires)
Pardon ?
Public : Hippopotame.
JBC : Hippopotame et anesthésie.
Alors, figurez-vous que lors d’un voyage
que j’ai fait en Afrique,
alors que j’étais sur le bord d’un fleuve
très réputé justement pour
les observations qu’on pouvait y faire,
notamment par rapport aux hippopotames.
J’étais là en train de regarder
et il n’y avait rien qui se passait.
C’était sidérant car, à aucun moment,
je ne voyais émerger de l’eau
quelque chose qui pouvait me laisser
penser que probablement, dans ce fleuve,
dans ce lac peut-être, on ne sait
pas trop, il y avait un hippopotame.
Et soudain, je vois deux yeux
qui émergent de l'eau.
Sauf que c'était deux yeux fermés.
La bête approche
et sort de l’eau un hippopotame somnambule
(Rires)
qui visiblement était en plein sommeil,
mais qui se déplaçait.
C'est ça qui était étrange.
Alors, je me suis demandé
s’il était anesthésié ?
Dort-il vraiment ?
Ou quelle est...
Je ne savais pas.
Après, j’ai étudié un peu la chose
et je me suis aperçu qu’une personne
s’est intéressée à cette chose-là :
Albert Einstein.
Encore lui.
Albert Einstein qui aimait
énormément les hippopotames
car il en avait eu un
en peluche quand il était petit,
(Rires)
se disait : «En fait, le réveil,
l’anesthésie ou la pleine conscience,
c’est quelque chose
qui est assez relatif.»
Et finalement, c’est à partir de là
qu’il a commencé à élaborer
sa théorie de la relativité.
Je sens que ça commence
à s’inquiéter en coulisses.
« Il ne va pas parler d’hippopotame les 15
minutes, ce n’est pas ça qui est prévu. »
Non, je ne suis pas venu
vous parler d’hippopotame,
je suis venu vous parler d’improvisation.
Cette petite introduction,
c’est une façon de vous montrer que
quand on ouvre son imaginaire,
on peut aller très loin
et surtout, on peut s’amuser
avec les codes et les règles.
D’ailleurs, connaissez-vous l’histoire
de cette photo d’Albert Einstein ?
Cette photo a été prise -
Albert Einstein sortait d’une cérémonie
donnée en son honneur
pour son anniversaire et il est accompagné
d’un ami universitaire et de sa femme.
Mais en sortant, il y avait plein
de journalistes et de photographes.
Albert Einstein, un peu stressé,
va, se faufile et rentre
dans une voiture aussi vite qu’il peut.
Mais un photographe s’approche
de la voiture, lui dit :
«S’il vous plait Monsieur Einstein,
un petit sourire encore.»
Et là, Albert Einstein,
énervé, tire la langue.
Le photographe prend sa photo
et c’est devenu une image
emblématique du 20ᵉ siècle.
Ça paraît fou, mais le plus intéressant,
c’est ce qu’a dit Albert Einstein après.
Il a dit : «Tirer la langue
à un photographe,
ça signifie qu’on refuse de se soumettre
au jeu de la représentation
et qu’on refuse de donner une image de soi
conforme aux règles du genre.»
Alors moi, je trouve
cette posture super forte.
Ça veut dire que pour se sortir
d’une situation angoissante,
il a changé la règle.
Et du coup, j'adore cette photo.
Je m’appelle Jean-Baptiste Chauvin
et je suis comédien
avec une particularité :
je suis comédien improvisateur.
Ça veut dire que ce que je joue
sur scène, je l'invente.
Et je suis aussi formateur :
j’enseigne l’improvisation théâtrale.
Mais surtout derrière ça,
je me suis aperçu d’une chose :
l’improvisation, quand on la pratique,
elle change notre vision du monde
et surtout notre façon
d’interagir avec le monde.
Pour autant, rien ne me prédestinait à ça.
Dans ma famille, il n’y a pas
d’artiste, ni de comédien.
Et le plus marrant, c’est que mon père
était extrêmement cartésien,
toujours dans l'anticipation.
D’ailleurs, il avait de qui tenir car
mon grand-père, lui, était polytechnicien
et il travaillait à la SNCF.
Chaque fois qu’il voyait un train,
il prenait sa montre :
«Ah ! En retard d’une minute !»
Avec un père et un grand-père comme ça,
j’ai choisi d’être improvisateur.
Cherchez l'erreur.
Tiens ! Pour savoir comme ça
dans la classe, en levant la main,
qui sait improviser ?
OK.
Qui ne sait pas du tout improviser ?
Ah ouais, je me rends compte
que pour la majorité, c’est... :
«Je ne sais pas.
Ça dépend des circonstances.»
Je vais vous dire une chose,
dans la salle, sans aucune exception,
vraiment sans aucune exception,
tout le monde sait improviser.
Car vous êtes tous capables
de produire des actes et de la parole
sans préparation.
Je dirai même mieux : vous avez tous
été les meilleurs improvisateurs du monde
car vous avez tous été des enfants
capables d’imaginer, d’inventer
comme ça, en direct,
sans vous soucier du temps qui passe
et même mieux, sans vous soucier
du regard des autres.
J’ai une petite fille de 6 ans.
Elle improvise tout le temps,
elle imagine sans arrêt,
elle se crée des mondes,
elle joue des personnages.
Elle laisse totalement libre cours
à son imagination, sans interdit.
Et du coup, elle construit des histoires.
Et du coup, elle donne corps et vie
à tout ce qu’elle veut.
Mais alors pourquoi
n’arrive-t-on pas à se dire :
« Moi je sais parfaitement improviser» ?
Ah, c’est parce qu’improviser,
ça devient beaucoup plus compliqué
quand il y a des conséquences.
Nous, au théâtre, on appelle ça un enjeu.
Par exemple, parler à un ami,
on le fait tous les jours, c’est facile.
Mais parler avec ce même ami pour lui
annoncer une mauvaise nouvelle,
ça, c’est plus compliqué.
Expliquer une idée à un collègue,
c’est facile,
mais expliquer la même idée
à 300 collègues en même temps,
c’est plus compliqué.
Dire à Micheline qu’on l’aime bien,
c’est facile,
mais dire à Micheline
qu’on est fou amoureux d’elle,
c’est plus compliqué
parce qu’il y a un enjeu.
Ces enjeux, on en a plein dans la vie.
Et chacun essaie de se débrouiller avec.
Alors des fois, on contourne
un peu le truc, des petites stratégies.
Le but étant de jamais perdre la face
et de toujours maîtriser la situation.
Mais le vrai problème, ce n’est pas ça.
Le vrai problème, c'est les autres.
Car les autres, je ne peux pas
leur faire faire ni dire ce que je veux.
Je ne peux pas les contrôler, les autres.
On est des êtres humains.
Et qu’on le veuille ou non, on est
socialement lié au monde qui nous entoure.
On est socialement lié à un monde
qu'on ne peut pas contrôler.
Alors, si vous rajoutez à cela
la nature avec tous ses effets,
il pleut, il n’y a pas assez de neige,
il y a des feux de forêt,
un tsunami, un tremblement de terre,
oh, tiens ! une pandémie.
Et face à toutes ces choses imprévisibles
qui nous entourent,
il y a deux sentiments inévitables
qui surgissent :
c’est la peur et la colère.
Alors face à la peur et la colère,
le premier réflexe,
ça va être de se protéger.
Heureusement, la nature n’est pas ingrate
et elle nous a donné un cerveau.
Alors on va l’utiliser.
Le cerveau, il nous permet
de penser, de réfléchir,
mais aussi d’anticiper, de prévoir,
d’analyser les expériences.
Bref, on va essayer de contrôler car
individuellement et aussi collectivement,
on veut prévoir
tout ce qui peut nous arriver.
On veut se prémunir de toutes
ces menaces qui sont autour de nous.
Alors on va construire tout un tas de
scénarios contre les crises possibles.
On va prévoir, on va se préparer
à tous les dangers possibles.
Mais dès qu’il y a un truc qui ne se passe
pas comme prévu, qu’est-ce qui se passe ?
Ben c’est la peur et la colère
qui reviennent.
Inévitablement, quand on veut
contrôler ça, on n’y arrive pas.
Et du coup, on se trouve toujours
face à un monde où l’échec nous domine.
Alors, quand j’enseigne
l’improvisation théâtrale,
la première chose que je dis aux gens,
c’est qu’on va jouer.
Le jeu, c’est un truc extraordinaire
parce que le jeu, ça suspend le réel.
Tout ce qui se passe dans le jeu,
ce n'est pas la vraie vie.
Par contre, le jeu,
même s’il suspend le réel,
il nous permet de vivre des expériences
pratiques et émotionnelles
qui, elles, sont bien réelles.
Quand je joue aux cartes
avec ma fille, à la bataille,
il n’y a plus une fille face à son père.
Il y a une joueuse face à un joueur
qui n’attend qu’une chose :
c’est le moment de la bataille
pour me piquer un as ou un roi.
Ça, c’est le jeu.
Mais derrière, qu’est-ce qui
est bien réel pour ma fille ?
Elle apprend à patienter.
Elle apprend à gérer ses frustrations.
Elle apprend à perdre.
Elle apprend à se laisser surprendre.
Ma fille avec ses copines n’arrêtent pas
de s’inventer des mondes imaginaires.
Mais tout ça, c'est le jeu.
Mais derrière le jeu,
il y a plein de choses réelles.
Elle apprend l’interaction
avec ses copines.
Elle apprend le compromis.
Elle apprend à créer collectivement.
Jouer, imaginer, rêver,
ce n’est pas se couper du réel,
c’est goûter au plaisir
d’en inventer un autre.
Je donne souvent des formations
en entreprise.
Je vous assure qu’une fois,
en deux heures de temps,
j’ai vu des banquiers se transformer
en bêtes féroces,
à quatre pattes,
en train d’attaquer des conquistadors
de l’espace, cravate au cou.
J’ai vu un directeur d’agence
se faire dévorer sous mes yeux.
Ouais, mais ça, c’est le jeu.
Mais derrière, pour ces banquiers,
qu’est-ce qui est bien réel ?
Ils se sont écoutés,
ils ont construit ensemble,
ils se sont fait confiance,
ils ont lâché prise sur
leur environnement social.
Et c’est ça qui est incroyable
avec l’improvisation,
ça débloque plein de choses,
plein de qualités individuelles.
Mais surtout, ça nous permet
de collectivement comprendre
que derrière chaque problème,
il y a une solution.
Parce que collectivement,
on va construire l’histoire
qui se construit au fur et à mesure.
Et quand on a compris ça,
on s’aperçoit que dans la vraie vie aussi,
on peut être l’acteur de la vie qu’on vit.
On peut se dire qu’à chaque fois,
dans chaque situation,
qu’elle soit bonne ou mauvaise,
on peut toujours se dire que les choses
peuvent se passer autrement
et qu’une autre histoire est possible.
Alors, il y a quelque temps,
il y a quelques années,
avec des collègues comédiens,
on enseignait l’improvisation
à des collégiens à Trappes,
dans les Yvelines.
Il y avait un jeune,
qui s’était retrouvé orienté
en BEP force de vente.
Il était marrant,
il avait de la tchatche :
Vendeur.
Sauf que lui, il n’avait pas imaginé
être vendeur et il se dit que...
En plus, il était petit, il était arabe
et il avait un bras un peu handicapé.
Et là, il s’est dit : «Je n’ai pas
d’autre alternative qu’éboueur
ou vedette,
sans diplôme. »
Donc il s’est dit : «Éboueur,
avec un handicap, ce n’est pas possible,
donc je vais faire vedette.
Comme je suis marrant,
je vais faire humoriste.»
Et ce jeune-là, vous le connaissez tous,
c’est Jamel Debbouze.
Eh bien, Jamel Debbouze,
30 ans après, il le crie
haut et fort encore :
«L’improvisation, ça m’a changé la vie.
Pourquoi ?
Parce que ça m’a appris à changer
le cours de mon histoire. »
Et des histoires comme ça, on en a plein.
Et pas seulement dans le spectacle.
Je repense à Samuel, un pharmacien
qui a fait de l’impro il y a 20 ans,
qui nous a dit :
«Jamais je ne serais devenu pharmacien,
si je n’avais pas fait de l’impro.
C’est parce que j’ai fait de l’impro
que j’ai pu regarder mon avenir
en me disant que je peux
choisir mon avenir.»
Ou une autre : Mounia qui est productrice
de dessins animés dans le monde entier.
Elle a même eu un prix aux États-Unis.
C'était la plus timide.
Encore une fois,
chaque histoire est possible.
Alors je vous propose un défi.
Je vous propose à vous aussi,
de changer le cours de l’histoire.
Chaque jour, vous allez essayer de faire
rire ou sourire un ou une inconnue.
Un mot, une posture, une petite phrase
décalée, une blague sur la situation.
Pas besoin d’être humoriste.
Pour faire rire ou sourire,
il suffit juste de créer de l’inattendu.
Parce que l’inattendu, c’est la clé
pour ouvrir les portes de l’imaginaire.
Et alors, comme dit
Albert Einstein, encore lui :
«L’imagination embrasse le monde.»
Et c’est ça, la vraie leçon
de l’improvisation.
Car souvent, on s’imagine
que l’improvisation,
c’est une façon de s’ancrer
dans le présent
pour mieux s’adapter au réel.
Oui, mais pas seulement.
L’improvisation, c’est un savoir-être
qui permet de construire l’avenir
sans jamais se soumettre
à la peur et à la colère.
Alors, vous aussi, autorisez-vous
à aller vers l’inconnu,
pour bousculer votre peur et votre colère.
Et alors, votre histoire
deviendra votre histoire.
Et alors vous passerez à côté
de la procédure, du règlement.
Vous vous en foutrez du fonctionnement,
Vous n’aurez plus de soucis
avec les risques et les conséquences.
avec le fait d’avoir peur des choses.
Votre avenir deviendra votre histoire.
Une histoire qui met en symbiose
les personnes et leur environnement.
Une histoire qui répond à l’inconnu,
non par l’angoisse,
mais par la créativité.
Une histoire où être deviendra beaucoup
plus important que faire, ou qu’avoir.
Alors dites-vous bien une chose :
dans chaque situation
où vous vous sentez coincé
parce que vous avez peur
ou que ça vous met en colère,
dites-vous toujours
qu’une autre histoire est possible.
(Applaudissements)